بيان هيئه الامن الفيدراليه الروسيه قامت
مجموعات اوكرانيه بالدخول الى اقليم
بريانس وفي قريه قامت باطلاق النار في
الشوارع مع اسر عن مقتل بعض الاشخاص ايضا
قامت باحتجاز في متجر في هذه القريه
وبالتالي تحركت قوات الجيش الروسي وعلى
الفور وتقوم الان بحسب هيئه الامن
الفيدرالي بالقضاء على المجموعه
الاوكرانيه
ومحاصره المكان والقضاء
على مجم
وعات وصلت لقرعه اخرى في قريه شوشاني ايضا
كانت هناك مجموعه حاولت القيام ببعض
الاعمال ولكن تم القضاء عليها بالاضافه
لذلك ايضا كانت هناك مسيره اوكرانيه في
منطقه
ولكن القوات الروسيه تمكنت من اسقاط هذه
المسير واضح تماما بحسب الانباء الوارد
سواء من هيئه الامن الفيدراليا وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ان هناك عمليات عسكريه
تنفذها القوات الاوكرانيه في اقليم بريانس
وهو اقليم حدودي ليس فقط مع اوكرانيا ايضا
مع بيلاروسيا وفي هذا الاقليم عمليا كانت
تجربه المفاوضات الاولى حول تسويه الازمه
الاوكرانيه شكرا لك مازن كنت معنا مباشره